It could be that my eyes are getting weak.
You'll see. He's gonna tell us the Greeks invented thunder and electricity.
The Chinese. Things always begin with them.
Oh, you think so, do you? And you think that you know it all?
No, Master. No, we're not like them.
Enough. You're gonna ruin a tremendous story again.
Tell us a story.
All right. But first of all, it's far too dark.
And suppose we switch on some light?
There's nothing very complicated in that.
You press on the button, and then there is light.
It's as easy as one, two, three.
Oh, yes, that's what everybody always says.
Every done, it's as easy as one, two, three.
And yet, scientists, even some of the greatest, Einstein included,
all admitted being perplexed by the phenomenon of electricity.
Ah, but electricity wasn't invented.
No, in fact, it's always existed before prehistory.
It's a big one, that one was. Look, there.
It set the forest on fire.
Who would ever have thought that lightning was electricity?
That it could prove useful, but then one day, 3,500 years ago...
That's it, now we get the Greeks.
I told you it's the Chinese.
From its land, these are the commandments of the Lord.
Our most precious possession, which we carry in the Ark of the Covenant.
The Ark will have to be in heavy stone, so the commandments will not be stolen.
No, my friend, it will have to be light.
We must be able to carry it easily.
But the treasure contained inside we must protect.
Well then, we'll see.
Gold inside and the inside of the ark must be covered with gold.
But why the inside?
No one will see it.
Just for added protection.
Sleep soundly.
Those are asleep.
Their great treasure is in that box.
Their greatest treasure, he said.
Nothing can stop us now.
Moses, how'd you do that?
It's a mystery that mankind will understand 2,000 years from now.
Hey, be careful, Moses.
The ark is very dangerous.
Look, look at those two.
Those with impure hearts will be struck down.
We are in no danger.
Is it true, Maestro?
It happened just like that?
Is it magic?
Was it electricity?
The Hebrews knew all about electricity?
The ancients knew a great many things.
Moses had just invented the condenser,
giving an electric shock to anyone touching the sacred ark.
Why didn't Moses get a shock?
Because Moses had a ground wire.
A ground wire? You mean he was earthed?
Exactly.
You recall, the golden threads of his sacred robe touched the ground.
The Chinese were familiar with the magnetic needles and were the first to make a compass.
Point's always in the same direction, and it could be useful for staying on course during a voyage.
I'm going that way.
Well, I'm, uh...
It's me who keeps the compass.
An Englishman, Francis Hawksby, invented the first mercury lamp without really understanding it, and it was soon forgotten.
A Dutchman, Pieter Meuschenberg, invented the laden jar that would store electrical charge.
It was a shocking event.
A Frenchman, the Abbey Nolley, invented all kinds of games.
I shall charge the ball with electricity.
There we are now.
I will pass the electricity into this iron chain.
In America, Benjamin Franklin was also studying electricity.
And all the way to the quay.
See?
The form of electricity being struck by lightning.
In Russia, another scientist heard about Franklin's lightning rod.
Franklin's lightning rod.
Professor Reichman, careful.
You've got it wrong.
How would you know?
You're not a scientist, are you?
No, but I still forgot it has to be grounded.
Earth, sir.
Professor Reichman was killed instantly.
And this accident should help you to understand how important earthing can be in a house.
I'll show you something.
Not that.
That's my lunch.
As you know, the current passes through these two pins.
This one, this one is connected to the earth.
That's how we avoid being struck by lightning.
Stroke, what is it exactly?
That is pretty simple.
As Michael Faraday would demonstrate,
the Earth is an electromagnetic mass.
The ground carries negative charge.
Above, there's a layer of dry air, the troposphere,
which does not conduct electrical current.
Still higher is the ionosphere,
mainly carrying positive charges.
They're called ions.
Charges on the bottom of these ion elements
will spark off a tremendous thunderbolt.
Cologne, a scientist named Galvani was also interested in electricity.
What are you doing, Lucia?
I'm boiling frog broth for Signora.
A bene. What is it, Lucia?
Frogs, sir.
Those frogs are all quite dead.
There, there. Whenever you turn your machine, Signor Galvani.
What's that? You turn the machine, I'll watch.
Turn it.
No, Signor Galvani. Your experiment is of utmost interest,
but I do not believe the frog stores up a reserve of animal electricity.
It's different metals which are acting on the frog's legs, and if you wish, I will prove it.
A disc of copper, another of zinc, I put a damp cloth, one of copper, one of zinc, and a damp cloth.
Another disc of zinc, and here's the result.
I had invented the battery, fundamentally important.
We use batteries every day of our lives and never give it a second thought.
And batteries have millions of uses.
What's wrong? I was doing an experiment.
Lightening, the compass, needle, frog's legs, that move.
All that is still electricity.
But still, nobody really knew what it was exactly or just what to do with it.
But then alone came a young Englishman, Michael Faraday.
That's enough for today.
That's all we have for dinner.
Oh, times are hard, children.
Mr. Rebo, my son Michael is a hard-working, honest lad.
He knows how to read and do figures.
He might be useful to you.
He's a good-looking lad.
I'll give him a try.
Begin with, you'll deliver newspapers.
Here you are, this is your day's work.
Much work for a whole day.
Oh, there, you're wrong.
You see, my newspapers aren't for sale, I rent them.
So you see, the first one you deliver to Mr. White,
and while he's reading it, you deliver the second to Mr. Bland,
and the third to Mr. Tyne.
The fourth, it goes to Mr. Roll.
Meantime, go back and collect Mr. White's paper and take it to Mr. Black.
Hard-working lad, my...
I'll take you on as an apprentice binder.
To make new bindings for these encyclopedias, they are very important.
Michael, haven't finished the work.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir, but I happened to see this article on electricity.
Apparently, it's a sort of vibration, a bit like heat.
I'm pretty sure that nobody really knows what it is.
And you, do you know what it is?
No, but I can try to find out.
Look here, Michael, you can read all the books you like.
You'll have to stay late and finish that work.
Oh, thank you, sir. I will, sir.
By the scientist, Sir Humphrey Davy, with demonstrations.
Young man, stop your pushing.
You wouldn't understand it anyway.
I'm sure I'll understand it as well as you do.
What a frontery.
Electricity is a phenomenon that is extraordinary.
Look, not thoroughly understood.
Perhaps my experiments will add something to solving the mystery of electricity.
I can't see any more.
Notes you sent to Mr. Faraday are pertinent.
And so, young man, you want to work in science?
Yes, Mr. Davy, that's what I want.
That's a thankless job, badly paid, and sometimes dangerous.
You still interested?
Oh, yes, I am.
Very well, since I need an assistant, I'll hire you, a trial.
You will receive one guinea per week and have a room over the laboratory, aprons and candles, and you will start tomorrow.
We're going to work with nitrogen trichloride to try and disintegrate this substance.
Put this mask on, the headgear, and all this tube.
First, we'll prepare a small quantity of trichloride.
Now, slowly mix all of them up.
Very, very slowly.
I'll make the mixture.
Place the tube there.
This time, we're going to succeed.
We'll increase them.
All the quantities.
Yes, sir.
These accidents won't prevent their traveling in 1814 to Rome.
It's a very special fish.
They make very powerful electricity.
May I touch them?
Funny.
Very funny.
We're going to study this, Mr. Veriday.
In 1820 in Denmark, a scientist Oersted is going to perform an experiment that will change Faraday's life and the lives of all humanity.
There's a relationship between magnetism and electricity.
Look at this compass. The needle points north. If I push it, it returns to the north.
But if I produce in its vicinity an electric current, then this needle is deflected.
You see, it turns. The closer I come with this wire, the more it moves from the north.
But if electricity and magnetism are really expressions of a single force,
if they're the same, yes, that could be it.
Good heavens, I'll be late.
I've got to hurry.
Mr. Faraday, motion of the time.
I'm very sorry, Mr. Barnard.
I was caught up in my work.
We expected you at five o'clock.
My daughter, Sarah, was quite put out.
Now, well.
Mr. Faraday, that I do not wish to see him or speak to him.
My sister, Sarah, wishes to inform you.
I heard what Miss Sarah said.
Sarah, please excuse me.
I'm sorry.
Edward, I said I do not wish to speak to Mr. Faraday.
She says.
Sarah, the attraction of love is like that of a magnet.
There is an induction generating movement. It's like that.
Please excuse me. It's important. I must go.
Comprehend many things, but they don't understand love.
To a basin of mercury, I place a magnet vertically.
An electric wire here is pinned to a small cork to make it float.
The other wire here into the mercury.
I connect the wires to a battery, it turns.
It turns around, it turns.
There is a magnet.
I really don't need it because the Earth itself is a magnet.
It can only mean the world is full of electrical and magnetic currents that interact.
The force is electromagnetic.
Ready and waiting.
I have an idea.
Come here, I want to show you something.
Just for a few minutes.
Come with me, quickly.
Here.
Showed it to me already.
Only think, if electricity creates movement, then movement should be able to create electricity.
Bring the crank, Sarah, please.
It's so pretty. How did you do it?
Here, I'll explain it. Look, Sarah.
Dinner will be burnt. Explain it to me later.
Here's how it works. There are lines of force, no rubbing and no contact.
Not a matter here of static electricity,
but the movement of the magnet creates a field of force which produces electricity.
My poor Michael, do you really believe that?
You, with no education, no scientific background, and not knowing mathematics,
you'd make such a discovery.
Why do you say that?
Why does my master say that?
He must mind him. He stole it.
Well, that is certainly a more likely explanation.
In any event, the machine does appear to create electricity.
Can any of you gentlemen explain how it does so?
Well, uh...
Gentlemen, it's because the Earth itself is an electrical and magnetic field.
The compass proves this by pointing north.
Lightning, which passes from clouds to the Earth, is conducting electricity.
I think there are particles which are displaced.
I name these ions.
These particles? These ions?
what an imagination any friction is going to rub electrical particles off the amber the amber wants
them back so to speak or to find other particles it attracts them and particles form fields in
the air everywhere they induce a current through this copper wire running for our lives like this
we're ions all together we make up an electric current all of us irons are negative you guys
You mean, as others?
Sure, it's positive.
Girls!
And, us do.
We do, but they go in the opposite direction.
Hey, take a look.
Yeah, you're right.
Have a meet.
We do, now and then.
I warn you.
It's a shocker.
Watch it.
Hold on.
Turning in a field of magnetic lines of force was one of the greatest inventions of the century.
The first dynamo.
And soon electrical generators would appear everywhere.
Maestro, we understand how electricity is used to make light and all that.
What is it exactly? Electricity?
To simplify, let's say that it's an energy that is a part of matter
and whose particles attract or repel each other.
That's what happened to the ions that you saw earlier.
Jig magnetism. Let's look at two magnets.
You see, like poles push away, unlike.
Electricity is also, if you like, a twin sister to lightning.
To harness it requires a conductor of some sort.
Astro, tell us, how big is an ion?
A million ions. Can you imagine them?
Oh, sure. Well, sort of.
Mm-hmm. A million times a million? Can you imagine that?
Well, that's kind of hard.
This is very hard, eh?
Well, a million times a million ions wouldn't cover the head of a pin.
Yes, ask your question.
These ions move, then?
Oh, no faster than the speed of light.
300,000 kilometers in one second.
The distance of the moon from the Earth.
Electricity is something about which we don't know a great deal.
Even I don't.
There we are.
So I'd rather imagine that it's a fairy.
That it is a massive force that man has managed to liberate.
Yes, it was with Faraday that the universe of Newton would end
and the notion of bodies attracting and repelling each other.
The world would be seen as a field of forces producing electricity.
It is to Faraday and other discoverers that we owe the understanding of electrical energy.
And without that energy, well, our world wouldn't be anything like what it is today.
Don't you think he deserves a loud cheer, kids?
This Michael Faraday who was just a simple blacksmith son?